[موسيقى]
حاليا ان الشرطه الاسرائيليه استخدمت
المياه العادمه في محاوله ابعاد المحتجين
عن منزل نتنياهو في اطار الاحتجاجات
المتواصله على ليس فقط على اقاله جالنت
وانما في اطار الاحتجاجات القائمه على خطه
نتنياهو ايضا رؤساء الجامعات وخاصه جامعات
البحوث اعلنوا بان الجماعات ستبدا اضرابات
وعدد ايضا من الاطباء في بعض المستشفيات
اعلنوا بانهم سيقدون اضرابا ولهذا هناك
اهميه لما قاله رئيس
النقابات العماليه في اسرائيل بانه سيكون
لديه بيان غدا بامكان هذا الرجل عمليا ان
يشل اسرائيل تماما ان هو اقدم على اضرابات
في المؤسسات وفي المرافق الاسرائيليه
المختلفه
ليتكامل ذلك مع الاحتجاجات على الارض بهذا
قد يصبح
بنيامين نتنياهو الحكومه امام ورطه حقيقيه
في الايام
المقبله المتوقع فعليا ان تبدا عمليه
التشريع ربما غدا او بعد غدا
لتعديل القانون قانون القضاء بالنسبه
للائتلاف الحكومي طبعا تتوالى الاحاديث من
اركان المعارضه اساسا ومن بعض نواب الكود
الذين يتحدثون للاعلام الاسرائيلي في
محاوله الدفاع عن قرار بنيامين نتنياهو